trump
to sign america first executive order
uncovered 19 and maybe out of that story
i'd much rather talk about trump
confirms he'll run for president 2024
and he's talking about a big launch i
don't know if you guys heard about this
or not
he wants to he wants to go out with a
bank he wants to go tell the world on
the same day
when uh uh what do you call it a biden's
gonna yeah yeah so trump is reportedly
planning a made to for tv exit on air
force one from the white house
to rally on inauguration day hoping to
pull viewers from biden president trump
is planning a made for tv exit
sources told the outlet that trump is
planning to fly to florida
on air force one to stage a rally at the
same time biden sworn in at a socially
distanced inauguration in dc
that would break with inauguration day
traditions designed to showcase the
stability u.s democracy
biden said last week that he personally
didn't care if trump attended his
inauguration but trump should go to
demonstrate a peaceful transfer of power
and trump has plans for the next four
years two
bash biden on a daily basis and make his
life a living hell
for the next four years to show what
they did to him trump wants to return
the favor
back to biden and then afterwards he
wants to run 2024
and he's planning on running and
campaigning for office the next
four years what are your thoughts
straight hold on yeah
trump lost the election he's leaving i
don't understand
hold on tom what's going on here he's
already planning
on going to mar-a-lago and he's already
planning on doing this air force one
thing
i think he needs to make sure that he
actually doesn't
lose this election first i don't like
the fact that he seems like he's
conceding
i don't like that at all i think he's
here i know your heart is appointing me
i think he needs to
try to hold it together adam you've
shown your true colors too easily
i think he needs to keep fighting i
think he's got this thing
um i know you're at 40 33
last tom's at 41 you know
if he somehow loses i don't know how he
would lose
but if trump somehow loses this is the
trumpiest move ever
in the middle of an inauguration making
it all about trump forget about america
forget about an inauguration forget
about a peaceful transfer of power
let's make it all about trump let's make
it all about
everything trump forget about america
let's just what's your point
what's your point this is just it's obvi
like
all beings in all seriousness if you
lose
you lost bro like this is like just
if if georgia does a recount yeah you
know he's making fun of brian kemp now
if arizona does a recount he loses
pennsylvania does a recount
at some point you know rudy giuliani i
know he's doing a great job right now if
he has no evidence
and he has nothing no merit and he loses
every single case
and you actually lose they count every
legal vote and you actually lose
at what point are you just a sore loser
at what point at what point do you say
look
as an american i have something i
believe i believe in american democracy
um and be uh for the for the good of the
country betterment of the country yeah
the betterment of the country good luck
with freaking sleepy joe
i lost but i'll be back in four years
this is not about me this is about
america
but you know i'll see you in four years
this is not about me
but if trump of course trump does not
have that in his body everything's about
trump
so even on an inauguration day he's
going to make it about himself i think
he's going to rent the goodyear blimp
fly over the inauguration and moon
everybody i think that would be one of
the things
that's not a grown-up move you know
here's the thing when you think of
donald trump he
and i wrote this yesterday in vt post he
named a 747
after himself casinos after himself a
gold-plated hotel after himself
a university after himself if you don't
think he's going to do something
unorthodox on inauguration day you don't
know donald trump
he definitely is here's the key phrase
joe biden says
break with tradition screw tradition
they broke with tradition by harassing
him for four years
and whatever had taken place in this
last election
with voter fraud quote unquote that's
breaking with tradition where we don't
count every vote
okay that's the biggest break with
tradition the other thing too is can you
imagine how happy cnn
and msnbc and the new york times and
everybody else would be if donald trump
did decide to
run for the 24 election and declare it
right away they'd actually have
something they could cover they'd be
relevant
again for the next four years and
finally i think trump's into doing
things that have never been done before
and i think him coming back in 2024 to
say i
told you so it would be the easiest mess
for him to fix and to clean up and i
think
he kind of is attracted to the scenario
of let biden bury the country and
himself and he'll come in
and save the day in 2024. okay let's
process this let's process this
on his decision to not want to show up
okay
not want to show up and do his own thing
uh
number one breaking tradition you're
right the tradition was
the uh sitting president doesn't get
criticized by the former president that
he
replaced okay well by obama broke that
tradition because for four years all by
all obama did his trash
trump every single day he had an
opportunity to talk bad about trump he
did it regularly not something bush did
to him
but something he did to trump and a lot
of democrats said
trump was doing the same thing to obama
ever i mean he was but he wasn't but
obama was doing that to bush all the
time every time something came up obama
would say well i know you have a very
good relationship but wait a minute but
because of bush not because of obama
they have a great relation because of
bush you think it's bush only not
of course it is because bush not once
said anything negative about obama
but obama said so many bad things about
trump bush never said anything the
ironic part is trump
likes to say that he inherited a mess
from obama obama
legitimately i said did i say bush did i
say that
no i'm saying that's what trump said
yeah but i didn't say that all right
say he inherited a message i'd let you
finish it
i'll let you finish okay so my point to
you is obama
broke the tradition of trashing the
current president
he couldn't help himself and obama kept
doing that over and over again and when
when trump tweeted and said obama has to
be the worst president of all time and
on jimmy kimmel or jimmy fallon he was
reading the tweets mean tweets
and obama said at least i'll go into
history books as a president and drums
to mike
and then at a dinner obama makes fun of
trump for 20 minutes
while trump was at the dinner sitting
right in front of him yeah oh
okay so i'm sorry buddy this is the
obama caused a lot of before trump was
even wrong
obama caused a lot of this to himself
okay
so he didn't do the classy thing himself
so let's take traditional that part's
cancelling both sides out
that's gone forget about tradition that
part's gone here's the next one
why doesn't he want to be there is it a
business deal
meaning does he want to go do a splash
media company here's what i'm doing i'm
going to compete with cnn fox all this
and stuff
i don't know i mean let's just say he
does that
is he gonna build a hundred billion
dollar company over the next five years
i don't think so
is he interested in taking his network
from three billion to twenty billion
what the hell is the difference
what is the difference between being
worth three million no one would believe
it anyway no no but the difference what
is the difference between being worth 3
billion and 20 billion nothing
you still get to go do the same thing 17
billion no but the what is the
difference
you still get to buy the 200 million
dollar home you still get to go to all
the nice restaurants you still afford a
747 private
a plane for yourself you still it's the
same thing life's going to be good
either
life's going to be better at three or so
is he trying to get that additional 17
billion what the hell is that going to
do is legacy
i don't think that's what he's going to
do so then it leaves me to what
is it a trump thing that he doesn't like
losing publicly and he's trying to save
face
okay i for sure see that because i i
don't think he likes losing
at all so he's going to try to save face
but he's lost many times in his career
he's lost a football league that he had
anybody herschel walker
and he lost that he had uh atlantic city
what he did over there he lost that
airline casinos airlines stakes but
nothing like this
trump university like you lost not your
company not your
real estate this is but he's lost he's
lost many many times he's also lost many
many times
so you don't become who he is without
having lost many times
and he's sitting there saying this guy's
a billion dollar in debt all that
he's lost many many times okay or
here's the last one here's the last one
or
he really believes
america's exceptionalism and the
american dream could potentially be lost
and he really sees these other guys
as enemies that could empower china a
lot because he learned a lot in the last
four years of what china's dealings are
and what other countries are really
doing and he's such a firm believer now
that his number one enemy is to go up
and make sure america stays at the top
and stays at as that country i said
maybe
these are the things i didn't tell you
what i know what's what
i said these are possibilities of what's
really going on
if it's the one that's about me z i know
i got four minutes i'm good with that
if it's about me well then he's going to
lose
legacy is not going to be good to him if
it's about me alone if that's at the top
if it's about we and it's about his true
beliefs that he has that he wants to go
out and fight for that part of america
well the legacy is going to benefit him
if he makes it and he wins 2024
and he goes back and we see how much
advancement china makes over the next
four years because here's the reality of
it
if during the biden administration china
becomes number one
that's on china that's on biden's legacy
as well if during biden's administration
china becomes number one
it's going to be the easiest thing for
trump to come in saying during his reign
china took over and became number one
then trump's going to come in to say
he's the only one that can go up against
china
again i'm setting this up i don't know
if this is the case or not
all i'm saying is if that's the reason
why he's doing what he's doing more
power to him
if it's for me it's not going to be and
by the way there's some jokes online
talking about i think you brought it up
saying imagine if trump and trump run
trump senior runs as president trump jr
runs as vp
that's like nepotism at the highest
level if that was to ever take place
but no one knows what's going to happen
the next way i think that was your
prediction that is my prediction i
believe it will happen
because he wants to keep it going
forward he wants to save the republican
party for the long term
uh and he can blame pence a little bit
too you can say that that didn't work
oh i i actually think pence he needs a
pence
i think he definitely
of evangelical christians look at the
martino booth when we had the martina
booth here what'd she say she said
you know she respects pence a lot she
doesn't respect trump
so so a pence is if you have a trump
trump what am i voting for
right you need a different people but we
are talking about that like it's the
reason biden picked the comments
right now trump jr is about to become
the president of uh np
uh uh well not npr what's the nra nra
he's about to be the president
that's what he's working on because
their family supports a lot of these
beliefs
so i got i got to give one pushback on
one thing yeah
and touche you're right about obama he
tried him you know
at least obama had trump to the white
house
look man let's be grown-ups i don't like
you you don't like me
cool you've trashed me yeah i mean
bro there's a big butt adam please
there's a big butt
don't stop it what how much hard time
did
the media give obama for eight years
zero
zero he was every article was is obama
the greatest president of all time
could obama be one the greatest
president of all time voters are saying
62 percent
believe that obama's greatest president
of all time how much of that have you
seen
anything for what he got a nobel prize
three months after being a president
what did he do
so media what does that have to do with
trump showing up to
everything because for four years all
the media did is
trash this guy nonstop it's non-stop
embarrassing and humiliating him for
four
straight years russia was a hoax the
dossier was a hoax by hillary clinton
no one covered it because it's not
necessary to cover
you know how pissed off anybody would be
if they manipulated and played games
like that with you for four years
i don't care who you are you could be
the biggest saint in the world that's
going to bother you
so tradition wise oh it is what it is
but
everybody broke a little bit of
tradition here the last four years ain't
nobody is saying
i think he needs to show up but i
understand why he's doing it
i think he needs to show up but i think
i understand if you were in here
his ear you'd be like look first of all
if i would my approach would be a
different approach but i'm not trump i
can't speak on behalf of a human being
how the guy's wired
the guy's been like that for 74 years
when people say what advice would you
give to trump
nothing the guy got to where he got at
74 years old on his way of thinking you
are not going to be able to tell the guy
what to do and by the way he can't win
either way they'd hammer him if he went
[Music]
yeah